ever wondered how to unlock your data
insights with bigquery stay tuned to
find out more
hi everyone i'm matild and i'm valeria
and we're both customer engineers here
at google cloud
welcome back to the technical guides for
startups a video series where we help
startups to start build and grow their
businesses successfully and sustainably
on google cloud platform
in our previous video we touched on
firestore and datastore to document
based databases optimized for your web
and mobile applications
and today we will be talking about
bigquery google cloud's fully managed
data warehouse that enables scalable
analysis over petabytes of data
in this episode we are going to cover
what is bigquery and where to use it
we look into building data etl pipelines
with bigquery
a goal over advanced features such as
bigquery ml and bigquery bi engine
then we will talk about bigquery pricing
and optimization
and take a quick tour into bigquery
console
and we will finish up with a customer
story
all right so let's get started with what
bigquery actually does
bigquery is at the core of google's data
cloud it is a data warehouse designed to
support all kinds of data sets including
massive data sets such as log data from
thousands of retail systems or iot data
from millions of vehicle sensors across
the globe
this very same architecture is used for
powering some of google's public
products
organizations rely on bigquery to
aggregate data from disparate sources
process it and make it readily available
for data analysis that support decision
making and innovation
storing and querying massive data sets
can be time consuming and expensive
without the right hardware and
infrastructure as a data warehouse
bigquery is designed to help you ingest
store
analyze and visualize big data with ease
you can simply ingest your data as batch
loads or streaming for real-time
insights
bigquery supports both structured and
semi-structured data such as json files
for example
with bigquery you can store massive data
sets up to petabytes of data in a
structured tabular format
there are two different objects to
notice in bigquery data sets and tables
tables will be your usual data in
tabular format and data sets will
regroup those tables as folders
to avoid storing duplicates of data you
can also federate bigquery with other
google cloud databases such as cloud
storage
without copying the data in bigquery
storage but simply making a connection
between products
in bigquery you can use standard sql for
easy and super fast querying on those
massive data sets for aggregation from
different sources and transforming your
data with data manipulation language
finally for visualization bigquery
easily integrates with reporting tools
such as looker spreadsheets google's at
no cost data visualization tool data
studio or many other products from our
partner ecosystem
let's dive into the different
characteristics of bigquery
what is bigquery google bigquery is
fully managed so you can focus on
analyzing your data up to petabyte scale
without worrying about the scaling of
the underlying infrastructure
google bigquery is ml predictive
enabling your data scientists or
analysts to build and operationalize ml
models
with only a few lines of sql you can
train and execute your models on data
stored in bigquery without needing to
move it around
google bigquery is real time
stream data and accelerate business
decisions by getting your analysis on
the spot
bigquery is multi-cloud and with
bigquery omni you can ingest and analyze
data from other cloud providers
so as you learned bigquery is a great
tool when it comes to data analysis and
enables users with quick access to the
data insights with no extensive
programming skills but what about large
data sets management and machine
learning
as you know boss required knowledge of
ml frameworks quite oftenly this
excludes data analysts who understand
the data but have limited ml knowledge
and programming expertise bigquery ml
empowers data analysts to use machine
learning through existing sql tools and
skills
without needing to move your data out of
bigquery with bigquery ml you can train
and deploy machine learning models
directly using sql bigquery ml takes
care of data extracting model training
and deploying for you
that means you've got data storage data
analytics and machine learning all
within bigquery
as your business data keeps growing in
volume over time your data analytics
pipeline have to be scalable to adapt to
the rate of change
let's see how bigquery can help us build
an atl pipeline to accommodate the scale
but first let's define what is a
pipeline and what does etl mean
a data pipeline is a series of data
processing steps each step delivers an
output that is an input to the next step
etl refers to a specific type of data
pipeline and it stands for extract
transform and load
another popular pattern is elt extract
load and transform the transformation
can be done inside of bigquery extract
refers to pulling data out of source
transform is about modifying the data so
that it can be loaded into the
destination and load is about inserting
the data into the destination this is a
common way for organizations to combine
data from multiple systems into a single
data warehouse
etl can be used to store legacy data or
as more typically today aggregate and
process data to analyze and drive
business decisions
bigquery is a great choice for your etl
data pipeline
let's take a look at the architectural
components of an etl solution for google
bigquery using google cloud dataflow
google cloud pops up
and google cloud app engine chrome as
building blocks
as an example we can build a task
orchestrator using google app engine
chrome service google cloud pops up
control topic and google cloud data flow
in streaming mode
then we will be using google cloud data
flow for importing bounded bachelor data
from sources such as relational google
cloud sql database for example mysql or
postgresql we as a gdbc connector
and then we will be storing the files in
google cloud storage
then google cloud dataflow will be used
for importing unbalanced streaming data
from google cloud pops up data ingestion
topic
and after that bigquery will be used for
storing staging and final data sets
an additional etl transformation will be
enabled via google cloud data flow and
ended sql statements
an interactive dashboard in data studio
can be connected to bigquery just to
visualize your data insights
all these components are examples of
fully managed services on google cloud
platform
with this architecture there is no
infrastructure for you to deploy manage
secure or scale and you only pay for
what you use
when it comes to data lifecycle
management it's important to take into
account data governance principles data
governance is everything you do to
ensure your data is secure private
accurate available
and usable inside your data warehouse we
recommend that you build your data
governance practice around three key
components
choosing the right framework that
enables people to define agree to and
enforce data policies
creating effective processes for control
oversight and administration over all
data assets across on-prem
cloud storage and data warehouses
platforms
and of course choosing the right tools
and technologies for overseeing and
supporting data policy compliance
bigquery offers built-in data protection
at scale
within bigquery users can assign data
set level and project level permissions
to help govern data access
and also we have data encryption set by
default to ensure data security at all
levels
so what does it cost you to use bigquery
let's take a look at pricing
you pay for storage
queries
and some ingestion and export use cases
storage costs are based on the amount of
data stored and has two rates based on
when the data was modified for the last
time
tables or partitions in long-term
storage meaning that they weren't
modified in the last 90 days
see their storage price drop by 50
query costs are either on demand meaning
that you'll be charged for the number of
bytes processed by query the first
terabyte process is offered
or flat rate
with flat rate you purchase dedicated
processing capacity to run queries at a
reduced price those resources are called
slots they are virtual cpus
with flat rates you can make commitments
by the second the month or the year the
rule of thumb is that you should
consider flat rate once your bigquery
processing cost exceeds 10k of dollars
of widgets note that you are not charged
for queries that return an error or for
queries that retrieve results from the
cache
loading and exporting batch data to
bigquery is at no cost you'll be paying
for streaming inserts and exports and
the use of the bigquery api
you can find the link to detailed
pricing in the description
and what about performance and cost
there are several ways to optimize them
in bigquery
let's start with query processing
you should only query the data you need
first
use the preview option to explore your
data before you write a query it's free
when you write a query avoid the select
all statement
filter your query as early and as often
as possible
and avoid sql entity patterns such as
joins that generate more outputs than
inputs
finally check how much your query is
going to be charged by seeing the number
of bytes processed in the ui or do dry
rounds to get an estimation of your
costs
use cash intelligently bigquery writes
all your query results to your table
you either explicitly identify the
destination table or it is cached as a
temporary table
temporary cached results tables are
maintained per user per project
there are no storage costs for temporary
tables
enforce cost controls to avoid human
errors enforce max limits on bytes
processed per query or at the user and
project level
partitioning and clustering your tables
improves query performance and can help
reduce costs by reducing the amount of
data processed by queries
you can partition by ingestion time
date time stamp or integra range for
example
active assist recommendations guide you
through the optimal billing model based
on your usage
the bigquery slot recommender helps
on-demand customer estimate the number
of slots when migrating to a flat rate
pricing and does so by providing four
options on a cost performance scale
concerning storage
keep in mind to enforce data retention
policies by setting up expiration at the
data set table or even the partition
level
also
make sure you leverage federated data
access you can avoid duplicate copies of
data by connecting bigquery to google
cloud storage and avoiding bigquery
storage costs
now let's take a quick tour to the
console
in this demo we will explore a public
data sets for new york city city bike
trips
in bigquery the eric is as follows here
i can see my project i can click on my
data set and my data set here contains
two tables city bike stations and cd
bike trips
i can visualize the schema of a table
which gives me the different columns
their type and their description
in details i can view the size of a
table
and the number of rows
here you can see we have a large data
set of more than 33 million rows
the preview window and this is my
favorite feature
allows you to visualize a part of the
table
and see what the data looks like without
performing any query
let's try to do a query now
it is very straightforward you simply
have to click on the query button and
compose your query with sql language
so here i'm gonna query the whole table
i am gonna disable the cache so you can
see how long it takes to query the whole
table
in bigquery you can also visualize the
number of bytes bigquery will process
with your query so you can keep an eye
on billing
so here let's wait and see how long it
takes for bigquery to query the whole 33
million row table
so here as you can see it only took 29
seconds to query the whole table
all right so here let's do another query
and see how fast bigquery is for more
complex queries
as you can see as soon as you group or
add a condition both the duration and
amount of bytes shuffled dramatically
decrease
you can perform any and very complex sql
query you want to make your analysis and
extract your insights
once you have gathered the information
you need you can save your results
either in another bigquery table google
sheets or csv or json file to share
externally within your drive or through
a local file let's export our results to
a bigquery table
i can now see the table added to my data
set and my project
the location of your table will be the
one of your data set by inheritance the
dataset can be located in a specific
region london
or a multi-region larger geographic area
like the us
location of your data is an important
concept for query processing and loading
and extraction of your data
be sure to try the query sandbox it lets
you explore bigquery capabilities at no
cost and confirm that it fits your needs
the sandbox lets you experience bigquery
without providing a credit card creating
a billing account or enabling billing
for your project
and if you wanted to see a real-life
example of a big query power in action
let's take a look at card.com an
e-commerce platform which helps to
democratize e-commerce by giving brands
of all sizes the full capabilities they
need to take on the world's largest
online retailers supported by the
startup program by google cloud and
google cloud solutions
their end-to-end environment empowers
retailers to keep more of their revenue
set up proven strategies for managing
all aspects of their business and act on
meaningful insights from customers data
every step of the way
so all in all bigquery is a go-to
solution when it comes to getting
concise from your data
we hope that this has given you a good
understanding on how you can get started
on bigquery coming up in our next
session we'll be covering how to run
spark and hadoop jobs on google cloud
and we will talk more specifically about
dataproc for hadoop clusters and
serverless park
don't forget to like and subscribe to
our youtube channel click on the bell
icon to be notified each time a new
video is posted
thank you stay tuned and we will see you
very soon in the next video
[Music]